une affluence habituelle avant
l'ouverture du magasin mais ce matin
objectifs de la plupart de ses clients à
acheter des masques
il ya internet chat clients détenteurs
d'une carte de fidélité a pu réserver
une boîte de 59 attendu à prix coûtant
soit 29 euros 54
cette procédure n'a visiblement pas
découragé des acheteurs sa pratique du
fait qu'on n'a rien mais d'intermarché
ont recouvert ni retirer des vases ou
craignez justement qui est un peu la
bousculade ce matin peut-être me lasse
tout ça c'est quid donc pour cette
enseigne de supermarché indépendant pas
question de connaître à nouveau les
cohues le début de confinement ce qu'on
voulait pas en fait c'est avoir des
débordements si vous voulez donc
aujourd'hui on contrôle en fait ce qui
se passe au niveau des masques par le
biais des mails qui sont envoyées comme
ça c'est nominatif la personne vient de
récupérer directement aux caisses les
acheteurs rencontrés sont venus pour se
préparer à la levée du confinement de
cette femme qui est familles d'accueil
pour personnes âgées veut utiliser les
masques dès aujourd'hui au prix coûtant
et fils est là le seul endroit où on en
trouve
une dotation notant que l'état accueille
encore maxime ces trois basques par
semaine et roman josi tier 3 par jour
c'est un petit peu juste ce magasin
arçons premières livraisons de 480 de
boîtes de masques
de quoi satisfaire un tiers des
détenteurs de la fameuse carte de
fidélité très prochainement l'enseigne
compte élargir la vente à l'ensemble de
ses clients